[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen und guten
abend fußball gibt's gleich von norbert
lehmann guten eindruck von mir heizöl
gas sprit alles ist teurer geworden wie
die ampelkoalition da finanziell
unterstützen will eines unserer themen
heute
günstiger tanken und einmalzahlungen
wegen der hohen energiepreise schnitt
der regierung ein weiteres
entlastungspaket
ein monat krieg die angriffe auf die
ukraine gehen mit aller härte weiter die
nato beschließt eine truppenaufstockung
an der ostflanke
und wieder ein höchstwert mehr als
300.000 menschen infizieren sich neu mit
corona mecklenburg vorpommern erklärt
das ganze land zum hotspot
im portemonnaie sind die hohen energie
und spritpreise längst zu spüren daher
will die ampel koalition jetzt die
menschen in deutschland finanziell
entlasten die ganze nacht durch
verhandelt spd grüne und fdp und
einigten sich am morgen schließlich auf
einer reihe von maßnahmen bevor wir
schauen wie die reaktionen darauf sind
zeigen wir ihnen mit welchem geld und
welchen entlastungen sie rechnen können
thomas concia
bürgerinnen und bürger entlasten soll
eine energiepreis pauschale einmalig 300
euro brutto pro person für erwerbstätige
auszahlung automatisch für jedes kind
gibt es 100 euro
auch wer sozialhilfe empfängt erhält
einmalig 100 euro
außerdem sinkt die energie steuer auf
sprit für drei monate heißt laut
finanzministerium ein liter benzin wird
30 cent günstiger ein liter diesel 14
cent das auto stehen lassen anreiz geben
soll ein nahverkehrsticket neun euro pro
monat zeitraum 90 tage
alternativen nutzen energie sparen das
ist überhaupt der kurs verbunden auch
mit forderungen etwa an häuslebauer ab
kommendem jahr ist für neubauten ein
höherer effizienz standard vorgesehen
stichwort dämmen und ab 2024 soll jede
neue heizung 65 prozent erneuerbare
energien nutzen
bedeutet gasheizungen einbauen in der
regel ist das nicht mehr möglich
die beschlüsse also milliarden schwer
aber es gibt kritik nicht ausreichend
seien die entlastungen sagen die einen
wie soll das bezahlt werden fragen wie
andere über die reaktionen andrea maurer
bis um acht uhr morgens haben die
koalitionsspitzen über das
entlastungspaket hart verhandelt am ende
hebt jeder parteivorsitzende dass für
die eigene partei wichtige ergebnis
hervor für uns als sozialdemokraten das
will ich hier betont ist ein kernstück
dieser verabredung heute nacht die
energiepreis pauschale wir machen bus
und bahn fahren so billig wie es in
deutschland wahrscheinlich noch nie war
wir werden den
spritpreis reduzieren beim benzin um 30
cent pro liter und beim diesel um 14
cent pro liter bei denen die entlastet
werden sollen ist die erste reaktion
gemischt zu wenig weil sie auch noch
teurer geworden mich wird schon sehr
freuen wenn ich einmal zusätzlich rennen
euro bekommen würde würde mir gerade
sehr viel helfen persönlich gut dass wir
so sicher wie finanzieren wir so noch
mehr steuern zahlen deutliche kritik
kommt aus opposition und verbänden es
ist sozial
unausgewogen weil als
bundestagsabgeordneter erhalte ich
genauso viel wie die alleinerziehende
mutter das ist ein problem und
vielfaches nicht klar wie es denn nach
90 tagen dann einige maßnahmen sind
befristet danach weitergehen soll es ist
eine große gruppe komplett vergessen
worden meine vdk mitglieder sind total
geschockt davon dass rentnerinnen und
rentner nichts bekommen wir sind der
auffassung dass es richtig ist bürger zu
entlasten da müsste mehr getan werden es
aber auch notwendig ist betriebe zu
entlasten nehmen sie eine bäckerei mit
einem hohen energiebedarf da vielen
antworten 13 milliarden hat das erste
entlastungspaket ende februar gekostet
für das zweite rechnet der
finanzminister nun mit einem ähnlichen
betrag die kosten werden in den
ergänzungs haushalt einfließen den
lindner möglichst bald vorlegen will und
der die neuverschuldung in diesem jahr
wohl auf rekordhöhen treiben wird
heute findet ein wahrer gipfel marathon
zum ukraine krieg statt nato g7 eu alle
treffen nach 1 in brüssel immer mit
dabei us-präsident beiden thema auch
mögliche weitere sanktionen gegen moskau
die g7 rufen russlands präsidenten zum
sofortigen kriegsende auf ina baltes
berichtet
dieses bild ist die wichtigste botschaft
des tages die großen industrieländer g-7
stehen zusammen im schulterschluss gegen
putin ich habe die g7 heute als einheit
wahrgenommen
zu allen gerade drängenden fragen die
weltweit zu beantworten sind
zusammenstellt einigkeit mit den großen
demokratien dafür hat sich joe biden auf
den weg nach brüssel gemacht im gepäck
hat er eher wenig weitere russische
personen und unternehmen kommen auf die
us sanktionsliste die verwendung
russischer goldreserven wird
eingeschränkt auch auf dem eu gipfel am
nachmittag zeigt sich noch mehr
sanktionen gegen russland sind kaum
möglich außer der größten dem boykott
von russischem gas und öl doch nicht nur
die deutschen sind zögerlich heißt die
österreichische position ganz klar es
wird mit uns kein gas embargo und
verwöhnen fahrer gegenüber der
russischen föderation geben das ist
derzeit nicht realistisch andere länder
sind bereit zum größten sanktions
schritt auch wenn sie abhängig sind von
russischer energie sanctions unsere
unternehmer sagen mir dieses embargo ist
notwendig wir müssen putin stoppen es
ist nur geld wenn du lebst wenn die
infrastruktur da ist kannst du das
wieder reinholen
finnland ist bereit noch mehr sanktionen
zu beschließen das energiethema ist
einfach das wichtigste wenn es darum
geht wie putin seinen krieg finanziert
doch im moment ist unklar ob putin
überhaupt weiter energie liefert er will
rubel für sein gas die europäer sind
dazu nicht bereit
das was wir bisher erfahren haben läuft
darauf hinaus dass es überall feste
verträge gibt in der die währung in der
bezahlt wird auch teil des vertrags ist
und das ist ja etwas was dann auch gilt
unter steht meistens euro oder dollar am
abend wird joe biden in dieser runde
erwartet ein eu gipfel mit us-präsident
das gab es zuletzt vor 20 jahren der
krieg lässt alle zusammenstehen
ablehnung also was russlands ankündigung
angeht dass gaslieferungen nur noch in
rubel bezahlt werden können anne
gellinek in brüssel was folgt daraus wie
will man russland antworten
europa denkt noch über eine antwort nach
den durch putins vorstoß sind die
europäer in eine erhebliche zwickmühle
geraten putin will westliche unternehmen
zwingen die täglich millionen von euro
in rubel zu tauschen um dadurch die
eigene währung zu stützen die aber ist
ja erst ins trudeln geraten durch
westliche sanktionen putins ziel ist es
also den westen dazu zu bringen die
eigenen sanktionen zu untergraben die
europäer reagieren erst mal abwarten
kanzler scholz sagte heute der vorstoß
von putin sei ja auch ein beweis dafür
wie hoch wirksam die sanktionen offenbar
seien österreichische und polnischer
energieunternehmen haben bereits
angekündigt dass sie auf gar keinen fall
in rubeln abrechnen würden also der
westen will sich in dieser situation
nicht von putin erpressen lassen aber es
schwingt die sorge mit dass wenn man
putins forderungen nicht erfüllt
möglicherweise russland seine energie
importe in den westen stoppen könnte
danke für diese einordnung anne gellinek
in brüssel
und die militärallianz nato will auf die
russischen angriffe auf die ukraine
antworten mit einer verdoppelung ihrer
kampftruppen den östlichen
mitgliedsländern und sie waren putin vor
einem einsatz von chemiewaffen in der
ukraine
angesichts des krieges bleiben
generalsekretär jens stoltenberg jetzt
ein jahr länger als geplant im amt bis
herbst nächsten jahres gunnar krüger
über das nato treffen am morgen kurz
nach 10 die nato macht den anfang in
brüssel es leitet der neue der alte
generalsekretär slogan 30 staats und
regierungschefs den schallt partner in
kiew doch der gibt kein kompliment
zurück
die nato muss noch zeigen was sie tut um
menschen zu retten sie muss beweisen
dass sie das mächtigste militärbündnis
der welt ist die welt wartet auf euch
die ukraine wartet
mehr waffen hilfe leisten die mitglieder
einen waffengang als bündnis schließen
alle aus europäer und amerikaner durch
us medien spekulieren blaupause für die
ukraine sei wieder syrien ein
chemiewaffen einsatz wie 2018 sei eine
reale gefahr sagte biden vor seinem
besuch frage wäre es eine rote linie für
die nato ich gebe ihnen keine
geheimdienstinformationen
aber wir hätten eine antwort die dem
einsatz angemessen wäre
konkreter wird das bündnis bei der
selbstverteidigung kampfgruppen künftig
auch in südosteuropa schon jetzt 30.000
soldaten
ihre ständige präsenz verbietet
eigentlich ein vertrag doch dem endziel
russland mit dem krieg nun selbst die
grundlage
das ist die neue realität das neue
normal darum gibt die nato darauf eine
dauerhafte antwort und die lautet
abschreckung und verteidigung
genau vor einem monat am 24 februar
hatte angriff russlands auf die ukraine
begonnen von norden aus belarus und aus
russland drängen russische truppen
schnell in richtung kiel vor wurden aber
den vororten gestoppt auch von osten und
aus süden über die annektierte krim
griffen sie an und brachten weliko paul
und kassen unter ihre kontrolle
hf und mario pohl sind weiterhin heftig
umkämpft über die aktuelle station
berichten volker dutschek und tim
rhomberg
das sind bilder die an kriegsgebiete
erinnern wie kirkuk im irak oder kubaner
in syrien aber das hier ist mario pohl
in der ukraine in europa bis vor einem
monat vor dem angriff der russen lebten
hier 440.000 einwohner jetzt zahlreiche
angriffe später sollen es nur noch rund
100000 sein es sind unmenschliche
bedingungen sagen augenzeugen ist vielen
lebensmittel wasser medikamente
das russische fernsehen zeigt wie pakete
verteilt werden kleine kartons mit einem
großen zelt drauf ausgegeben von
russischen soldaten ein zynismus des
krieges von den russen beschossen dann
von den russen versorgt angelina will
ihren nachnamen nicht nennen und steht
mit mann und baby in der schlange
sie haben uns ein wenig brot gegeben und
windeln für die kinder und wir haben
haferflocken für das baby bekommen
85 kilometer von mario pohl entfernt den
bert jansch feiern die ukraine heute die
eigene marine denn im hafen brennt ein
russisches schiff soll ein
landungsschiff seien die osk das schiff
mit dem die ersten russischen panzer vor
drei tagen an land gebracht wurden
nach kiew erst wenn die hauptstadt fällt
der präsident besiegt ist ist das
strategische ziel aus sicht der russen
erreicht nach einem monat hat das
verteidigungsministerium
1800 luftangriffe auf das ganze land
gezählt aus ukrainischer sicht werden es
täglich mehr weil sich die russen am
boden nicht durchsetzen könnten
unsere feinde haben in den letzten 24
stunden 250 luftangriffe geflogen 60
mehr als noch am vortag
ein monat krieg in der ukraine das hat
den menschen viel abverlangt auch dass
sie ihre angehörigen und freunde in
aller schnelle vor dem haus dem
wohnblock beerdigen müssen
die un vollversammlung in new york hat
in einer weiteren resolution russland
für seine angriffskrieg in der ukraine
verurteilt in dem beschluss fordert sie
die sofortige einstellung der
feindseligkeiten
insbesondere alle angriffe auf die
zivilbevölkerung und zivile ziele
140 von 193 ländern unterstützen die
resolution nur fünf stimmten dagegen und
die abstimmung verfolgt hat für uns
johannes hano in new york johannes ist
es jetzt die zweite abfuhr für russland
bei den un wie es das einzuschätzen
wäre aus meiner sicht sind zwei dinge
hier bemerkenswert zum einen ist einmal
mehr klar geworden dass russland in den
vereinten nationen mehr oder weniger
isoliert ist die ganz überwiegende zahl
der staaten hat sich ganz klar gegen
russland gestellt sieht russland als
aggressor fordert die sofortige
einstellung und bedingungslose
einstellung aller kampfhandlungen und
den schutz der zivilbevölkerung und
haben ja gerade schon gehört 140 staaten
haben sich hinter diese resolution der
ukraine gestellt russland hat versucht
diese resolution zu verhindern aber
wieder nur die üblichen verdächtigen auf
seine seite ziehen können syrien eritrea
weißrussland und nordkorea aber es hat
sich noch etwas gezeigt und zwar dass
die un-generalversammlung mehr und mehr
die funktion des un-sicherheitsrates
übernimmt der praktisch handlungsunfähig
geworden ist durch die vielen vetos der
vetomächte nun ist klar dass die
resolution der un generalversammlung
nicht die gleiche rechtliche
bindungswirkung haben wie die der
sicherheitsrat ist aber sie erhöhen den
politischen und moralischen druck auf
russland enorm sagt johannes hano
immer mehr menschen aus der ukraine
fliehen vor dem krieg in ihrer heimat
aus der eu gibt es keine klaren
aufnahmequote so forderten die
innenministerin und minister der
bundesländer heute eine gerechte
verteilung innerhalb der eu allein in
deutschland sind bisher
246.000 geflüchtete registriert worden
wie sie hierzulande verteilt werden
zeigt dort stürmern
cottbus ankunft sonderzug am neuen
dritten verteilt rück kreuz deutschlands
um 250 geflüchtete für nahezu alle geht
es direkt weiter nach irgendwo in
deutschland
wir wissen nicht wo wir hin wollen sagt
ascher aus rath versuchen einfach einen
ruhigen ort und so ist das fehlen egal
in welchen der busse sie jetzt steigen
etwa nach süddeutschland auf zunächst
vier sonderzüge täglich maximal 1500
ankünfte stellt sich cottbus 1 bleiben
sollen hier die wenigsten
das ist das ziel zu verteilen sonst
säuft eine stadt ab und das nutzt
niemand was denn cottbus sei bereits
fast ausgelastet genauso wie viele orte
in brandenburg dazu berlin da schon weit
über dem aufnahmen die mit liegt auch
deswegen deutscher bund länder gipfel in
brüssel hier wollen deutschlands
innenminister auch andere eu länder
stärker zur aufnahme bewegen wie weit
können flugzeuge direkt von flughäfen in
polen
flüchtlinge in andere europäische
staaten bringen um auf die weise zum
beispiel eben auch brandenburg und den
raum berlin zu entlasten doch einer
verbindlichen aufnahmequote erteilt die
eu eine klare absage es gibt weiter nur
kleine lösungen etwa zwischen polen und
frankreich hier laufen bereits direkte
weiterleitung per bahn allerdings sind
gerade mal drei französische städte
immerhin ab nächster woche will die eu
einen index erstellen um endlich genau
zu wissen wie viele flüchtlinge schon in
welchem eu-land untergekommen sind
und nach unserer heute sendung können
sie ein zdf spezial sehen mit dem titel
krieg in europa gipfeltreffen in brüssel
um 19 uhr 30
schon vor corona war die finanzlage bei
den gesetzlichen krankenkassen
angespannt jetzt fehlen ihnen für das
kommende jahr 17 milliarden euro sowie
spitzenverband wie kann das milliarden
loch gestopft werden unter anderem
sollen die beiträge erhöht werden meint
gesundheitsminister lauterbach was er
nicht sagte um wie viel die
krankenkassen wünschen sich eine
entlastung durch den bund und bei den
crooner zahlen gibt es wieder einen
neuen höchstwert bundesweit hat das
robert koch-institut 318
1387 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages registriert
23.000 456 mehr als vergangenen
donnerstag 300 todesfälle kamen binnen
24 stunden dazu die sieben tage incident
steigt auf
1.752
besonders hoch sind die krone
neuinfektionen in mecklenburg vorpommern
die sieben tage ins events ist in dem
bundesland inzwischen auf 2.400 22,4
gestiegen das ist der höchste wert
bundesweit nun hat der landtag das
gesamte land zum hot spot erklärt und so
die korona maßnahmen bis zum 27 april
verlängert an der stadt fällt berichtet
hausmannskost serviert matthias steiner
seinen gästen am liebsten ab anfang
april sollte seinen gasthof wieder wie
gewohnt laufen ohne masken und tests
jetzt hat der landtag in schwerin die
verlängerung der korona schutzregeln bis
ende april beschlossen ein großer
wettbewerbsnachteil sagt einer wenn das
hier so deklariert ist und andere
bundesländer haben das nicht dann werden
gäste studierende unter einem fahren wo
sie halt denken da sind sie gefühlt
sicher alle landkreise und die
kreisfreien städte und damit faktisch
das gesamte land werden zum sogenannten
hotspot erklärt so war das im bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz eigentlich nicht
gedacht die hot spot option sollte nur
für einzelne regionen gezogen werden
können doch gesundheitsministerin drese
verweist auf die viel zu hohen instanzen
überall land und das macht die situation
ebenso kritisch in mecklenburg
vorpommern dass ich als
gesundheitsministerin diese hotspot
regelung unbedingt ziehen möchte das
infektionsgeschehen belastet derzeit vor
allem pflege und klinikpersonal
auf den normalen stationen einen
absoluten rekord an corona patienten wir
haben hohe personalausfälle in den
kliniken und auch auf den
intensivstationen ist die situation sehr
angespannt
also weiter testen den restaurants und
hotels kurzform ostergeschäft befürchtet
die tourismusbranche weitere einbußen
das wird nur dazu führen dass bei uns in
der branche inhalt arbeitsplätze
gefährdet sind und wir nach zweieinhalb
jahren pandemie als eine branche die
wirklich die hauptleidtragende ist
weiter ja gegängelt wird in mecklenburg
vorpommern haben die touristiker kaum
noch hoffnung auf einen gelungenen
saisonstart
ein relativ hohes gehalt und einen
dienstwagen für seine damalige frau
schwere vorwürfe jetzt wurde der
frankfurter oberbürgermeister peter
feldmann von der spd wegen korruption im
amt angeklagt das hat die
staatsanwaltschaft offiziell bekannt
gegeben sollte das gericht die anklage
zulassen käme es zu einem prozess gegen
den 63 jährigen der seit zehn jahren dem
mainmetropole regiert mehr zum fall
feldmann von andrea meuser und enkeln
klinge erst nur gerüchte heute die
anklage frankfurts oberbürgermeister
peter feldmann spd wird vorgeworfen er
habe sein amt genutzt um seiner
damaligen lebensgefährtin im jahr 2014
eine lukrative stelle bei der awo zu
verschaffen und zwar ging es um die
stellung der leiterin einer
deutsch-türkischen kindertagesstätte der
angeschuldigte soll auch gewusst haben
dass seiner damaligen lebensgefährtin
ein über tarifliches gehalt gezahlt
wurde und dass er zusätzlich noch ein
dienstwagen zur verfügung gestellt wurde
ein deal auf gegenseitigkeit denn nun
soll fällt man sich bereit erklärt haben
die interessen der awo in frankfurt
wohlwollen zu berücksichtigen der op
heute nicht greifbar aber er beteuert
seine unschuld endlich ein verfahren
gibt mir die möglichkeit mit den
maßlosen verdächtigungen aufzuräumen was
ich bisher von seiten der
staatsanwaltschaft gehört habe steht auf
tönernen füßen
ganz so tönen scheinen aber weder
mitglieder der stadtregierung noch die
opposition die vorwürfe zu finden kritik
von allen seiten
jetzt ist allerspätestens der zeitpunkt
gekommen wo er auch zurücktreten muss um
konsequenzen aus der situation zu ziehen
und die stadt vor weiterem schaden zu
bewahren haben wir die forderung erhoben
dass er fällt man keine öffentlichen
termine mehr wahrnimmt sollte er nicht
auf unsere forderung eingehen kommt dann
die zweite stufe es geht davon aus dass
wir dann am montag seinen rücktritt
fordern frankfurt wartet auf einen
spannenden prozess
und jetzt gehts zum fußball da geht es
ja um die letzten tickets für die
weltmeisterschaften ja heute abend viel
spannender halbfinal playoffs mit
wirklich großen namen was die nation und
die spieler betrifft etwa wenn portugal
und cristiano ronaldo auf die türkei und
trainer stefan kunz treffen
die türkische nationalmannschaft will
nach 20 jahren wieder zur wm doch dafür
muss zunächst portugal besiegt werden
gegen die noch nie ein pflichtspiel
gewonnen wurde
juliana klinge und wir spielen nicht nur
gegen ronaldo sondern gegen elf spieler
mit große karriere
perfekt
doch einer sticht heraus cristiano
ronaldo 37 es könnte seine letzte wm
werden die portugiesen keinesfalls
überheblich vor dem anpfiff
meist wissen dass das ein finalspiel
wird alles kann passieren aber
hoffentlich kann portugal seine stärke
beweisen egal wer gewinnt auf den sieger
wartet wohl noch europameister italien
trotz des angriffskriegs auf die ukraine
hat russland fußballverband jetzt sein
interesse an der austragung der
europameisterschaften
2028 und 2032 bekundet die uefa hat die
bislang nur russische vereine und die
nationalmannschaft von allen
wettbewerben suspendiert nicht aber den
spitzenverband es wird damit gerechnet
dass die europäische fußball-union dies
nun nachgeholt um eine offizielle
bewerbung russlands zu verhindern
die am letzten freitag abgebrochene
bundesliga partie zwischen bochum und
gladbach wird mit 2 0 für die gäste
gewertet
in der 68 spielminute wurde
schiedsrichter assistent christian kittl
man von einem getränkebecher am kopf
getroffen danach wurde die begegnung
beim stand von 2 0 für die borussia
abgebrochen das dfb sportgericht
entschied heute bochum trage die
alleinige verantwortung kein
wiederholungsspiel
zur frauen fußball champions league da
haben die wolfsburgerinnen knapp 1 sieg
verpasst im viertelfinal hinspiel gegen
den hat ging der vfl gegen gastgeber fc
arsenal in der 19 tabea wasmuth in
führung musste dann aber doch noch in
der 89 minute den ausgleich für die
london durch lotte war
aber insgesamt eine ganz gute
ausgangsposition für das rückspiel in
einer woche danke schön aber bitte
sonnig und trocken das sind die
aussichten das wetter gleich von katja
honnefer das heute-journal können sie um
21 45 sehen mit christian sievers und
morgen begrüßt sie hier an dieser stelle
barbara hahlweg ich sag auf wiedersehen
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend da hatte sich doch mal ein
wolken fällt gebildet hier über
norddeutschland das hat sich aber
innerhalb von nur wenigen stunden am tag
danach aufgelöst und dann strahlte die
sonne wieder vom blauen himmel prompt
gab es temperaturen bis 22 grad an der
donau jetzt nacht wird erstmal wieder
kalt in der osthälfte da sinken die
werte auf 0 bis minus 3 grad an der
ostsee und ganz im westen bleibt es bei
sechs bis null grad etwas milder und es
bleibt bei klaren sternenhimmel auch
morgen über tag gibt es wieder viel
sonnenschein und allenfalls über den
westlichen mittelgebirgen entwickelt
sich meine quellwolken das hat auch zur
folge dass in nordrhein westfalen aber
auch am rhein ist morgen eine sehr hohe
pollenkonzentration geht das sind eschen
pollen und die aller ersten birkenpollen
kribbeln auch schon der einen oder dem
anderen in der nase der wind weht meist
nur an der küste spürbar aus westlichen
bis nordwestlichen richtungen und so
steigen die temperaturen an der nordsee
auf 13 bis 15 sonst auf 14 bis 18 und
hier richtung mittel- und oberrhein und
neckar auf 19 bis 20 grad an diesem
wetter ändert sich auch in den nächsten
tagen wenig in norddeutschland wird es
etwas wolkiger und kühler guten abend